intel has been the biggest name and
processor production for many many years
but recently they've started to lose the
race to not only their main rival AMD
but to some new names in the game like
Qualcomm Samsung and even Apple well
there's a lot that's happened over the
years that we can't get into in such a
short video like this let's quickly go
over some history of Intel's battle with
AMD for the PC market for many years AMD
CPUs were once seen as inferior compared
to Intel's so they started investing
their resources trying to catch up while
building their own tech into their CPUs
and in 2003 AMD released a heavy hitter
Athlon 64 bit CPUs which for the first
time were superior to Intel's offerings
at the time with AMD putting a big focus
on gaming Intel rush to catch up on
64-bit CPUs and it wasn't until 2006
when they released their Core 2 Duo
processor their first dual-core
processors that destroyed the mainstream
CPUs AMD was offering and shortly after
AMD started producing their Athlon x2
dual-core processors and then they would
both venture into quad core and beyond
and while all this was happening PC
gaming was starting to get really
popular and a lot of gamers had to
decide between a mainstream Intel
processor or a more budget-friendly AMD
CPU being in my early teens back then I
went with AMD's Phenom - 955 Black
Edition quad core processor that I was
able to overclock and run some of my
favorite games and while AMD was
focusing on putting out more cores until
decided to mostly stick with quad core
processors for many years enjoying the
bulk of the market share and providing a
wide range of processors for companies
like Apple all the way from low-end
chips to high-end Xeon server chips in
the meantime there were some new players
entering the game in 2011 ARM Holdings
announced their first 64-bit mobile
chips and in 2013 Apple announced the
iPhone 5s the first 64-bit smartphone
packin their own a7 chip and with
smartphones becoming increasingly more
popular Apple and Android smartphone
makers continue to fight to create the
fastest mobile processors for our phones
but no one is expecting mobile chip
performance to grow so quickly we'll dig
deeper into that in just a minute with
AMD being the runner-up to Intel they
never stopped pushing for new attack
that could finally disrupt Intel's
market share streak and in 2017 this
happened take a look
our rise in product this is one of the
first off of the manufacturing line with
an incredible amount of horsepower under
the hood AMD released their first line
of risin seven processors offering a
very impressive performance for much
less cash than intel's competing chips
while this was happening Intel was
already in trouble having a very hard
time moving their 10 nanometer process
in fact in 2013 Intel claimed it could
produce 10 nanometer chips by 2015 then
they changed it to 2016 then to late
2017 and then late 2019 and here we are
in 2019 and we're finally starting to
see some mainstream 10 nanometers which
we'll get into in just a moment so what
was Intel's response to AMD announcing
Rison they brought hyper-threading to
their i-5 and they continued to squeeze
out every bit of performance they could
out of their 14 nanometer process while
beginning to finally lower their prices
to be able to compete with AMD and at
the same time
AMD was going full force with horizon
and threader per processors continuing
to improve performance while reducing
processor costs compared to in Seoul's
offerings in 2018 AMD was the best
performing stock on the SMP 500 and in
the past year it's basically doubled in
value gaining a lot of attention from
mass media and consumers around the
month ago AMD revealed the spec of their
upcoming 7 nanometers n2 processors at
Computex 2019 with performance that
completely destroys everything that
insel has to offer and being lower
priced in just a few days ago the
world's first 7 the animators then to
desktop CPUs from AMD are now available
to purchase shortly after that an
internal Intel memo was leaked admitting
the AMD's news and to processors will
offer great performance results with
prices there are significantly below
Intel's
offering good performance per dollar
however Intel also announced their new
10 nanometers isolate processors at
Computex 2019 and they're packing more
performance and a lot of new technology
like integrated Thunderbolt 3 their 10
nanometer chips are coming to thin
laptops and tablets first like Dells
2019 XPS 13 2 & 1 which should be coming
soon unfortunately it may be already too
late for Intel they've been behind for a
couple of years now
giving AMD a chance to swipe up some
market share especially since
have been experiencing some major
security issues with the recent specter
and meltdown vulnerabilities Intel is
going to have to come back strong in the
years to come to compete with AMD but I
haven't even talked about the
relationship with Apple and how they
could be losing their business very soon
as many of you know Apple's MacBook Pros
have been experiencing thermal issues in
the recent years and here's why
while Intel was promising that they're
more efficient 10 nanometer processors
would be coming soon Apple is working on
their 2016 redesign of the MacBook Pro
making it as thin as they could possibly
make it while packing awesome
performance unfortunately Intel's 10
enemy two processors weren't ready for
the initial 2016 release of the MacBook
Pro so Apple had to stick with Intel's
old 14 nanometer processors which were
fine for the time being but Apple and
their MacBook Pro is thin and very
limited cooling systems weren't
expecting Intel to delay 1080 meter for
so long and when Intel started to
increase core count to keep up with
AMD's rising processors the MacBook Pro
started to throttle really bad
especially with the last year's Intel 6
core I 9 processor this has caused Apple
some very bad press coverage pushing
users to believe that MacBook Pros can't
handle the heat of Intel's latest
processors in the meantime Apple's
mobile ARM chips have been getting
faster and faster every year especially
since the release of their 2018 iPad pro
packing their a 12 X processor which had
performance that surpassed 92% of all
laptops tablets and convertible PCs sold
before its release so the question a lot
of people have is why not just switch to
these armed processors and ditch Intel
well that's exactly what Apple has been
working on
they started the process by creating
their t2 chip which takes over a lot of
processors that Intel processors used to
do and they've been working on making it
easier to poor iOS software over to the
Mac which will in turn make it easier
for an ARM processor to run Mac OS when
this happens it'll become cheaper for
Apple to produce their Mac's
and Intel will slowly start to lose
apples business and that's not the worst
part other companies will follow in
Apple's footsteps and start replacing
Intel processors with ARM chips their
only chance will be to step up their
game and make processors that can
compete with AMD and these up-and-coming
powerful arm chips if
enjoy this video make sure to tap that
like button and click that circle above
to subscribe thank you guys for watching
this been max with max tech and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]